Speaker 1: Kerry lake is still. Doing her thing.
Still lying as much as possible. And specifically,
of course, about the election that occurred in
Arizona, where she lost. As much as she doesn't
want to believe that she did indeed lose. I want
to check in on Carrie Lake, what's been going
on with her. And it's kind of more of the same,
except I think as time goes by, she gets more and
more delusional as she gets further away from any
reality in which she's even on a timeline close
to win that election occurred. And her delusion
just increases as the time goes by. So here's her
actually getting asked if she would run against
Kirsten Cinema for Senate. Yikes. I don't love
thinking about that possible reality. Take a look.
Speaker 4: I know that polling has been done
showing that I would beat Kirsten Cinema and
I've had I'll be honest, I've had many, many
people reach out to me and all kinds of people
reach out to me suggesting that I run for Senate.
My focus 100% is on my election lawsuit. The
people of Arizona were done wrong. Their sacred
vote was trampled upon. And I am fighting to
restore honest elections in Arizona. I you know,
I want to be very obvious here, and I'm speaking
something very obvious. D.C. is messed up. It's
corrupt. Arizona is corrupt. And we need good
people in the Senate and our governor's office
at the state level and at the federal level to
fight this corruption. So I am focused right now
on winning this election and getting Katie
Hobbs thrown out of the governor's office.
Speaker 1: So. The fact that she's still saying
she's focused on winning an election that happened
in November and the victor of that election has
already taken office is wild. And it's what we saw
with Trump still calling for him to be president,
him to be, you know, put into the White House
because of the horrible wrongdoing. And as we will
repeat a million times with these types of claims,
you have to have evidence to make such dangerous,
dangerous claims. And she doesn't have it. And
when she went to court, her lawsuit was thrown
out because she didn't provide the evidence that
she's appealing and appealing. But this is the
reality and she's can't accept it. And so it's
quite wild to watch. I have a few more moments
just to update you on recent interviews with
Kerry Lake. Kind of a. A broken record, I'll say.
Speaker 4: All right. We will not accept defeat
because we won this race. The people show.
Speaker 1: Did not.
Speaker 4: Put up in massive numbers and they are
so afraid of we, the people, the political elite
is so afraid of we the people that they stole
this in broad daylight. They sabotaged Election
Day. And if we lay down and let them do this to us
now, we will never have a country. So we will not.
Speaker 1: And luckily we got through
the Katie Hobbs swearing in without any.
Devastating event brought on by supporters
of Kerry Lake. But each time these claims are
perpetuated, I get concerned because we know where
these lies can lead, and it really is dangerous.
Here is another example of her just making
the rounds, making the same dishonest claims.
Speaker 4: If they think they can steal an
election and make this movement of we, the people
of Mama bears and papa bears who care about their
kids of grandma and grandpa and students just go
away, They've got another thing coming because
we're going to work through the court system and
we will be victorious. We're not letting them.
Speaker 1: What's interesting is all of those
proclamations, we will be victorious. And we
see with individuals like Mike Lindell always
predicting, no, in two weeks Trump is going
to become president once again. And they never
seem to learn the lesson. And by they, I mean
the followers of individuals like Kari Lake,
Mike Lindell, Trump, who say we're going to be
victorious. Kari Lake saying, I'm definitely
going to end up governor. And then when it keeps
not happening, why is there no trust lost? One
more thing to show you, Republican Arizona State
Senator Wendy Rogers. I want to show you how this
spread and how this is still very much a movement
that's alive that is very concerning. Bolstering
these claims and pretending like there's some
chance in the world that Kari Lake could become
governor before the end of Katie Hobbes's term.
Speaker 5: Kari Lake should be our governor. She
was elected, it was stolen, and her case is on
appeal right now. It will meet the appeals court,
which is a three judge court here in a couple
of weeks. It will still go beyond that,
irrespective of that outcome to the Arizona
Supreme Court, where we hope for a final
justifiable resolution of this situation.
Speaker 1: We already have a resolution.
Katie Hoff was one. Now she's the governor. That
is the resolution. So one of the things I talk
about a lot is when answering the question of
why is it important to talk about individuals
like Kari Lake, she's not in power. Neither is
Trump. But why should we still discuss them?
The reason is, while the MAGA ideology lost,
I would say, in the midterms and the American
people generally were against it, it still is
very much prominent within our current political
reality and holds a lot of people within that
ideology. And so to understand the movement,
to address and confront the movement, we
have to check in with and look at the lies
being told by the leaders such as Kari Lake,
who commands that movement. And it is very
dangerous stuff going on as you saw there. If
you like what you're seeing and you're watching
this on YouTube or listen to the podcast or
wherever you are consuming this content and
you want to check out my show, you can go
to Luke Beasley on YouTube. There should be
a link in the description if you're watching
on YouTube. Quick break. We'll be right back.